welcome everybody to a video on the
Falcon large language model falcon 40b
instruct is the Top Model on the hugging
face large language model leaderboards
but how good is it in practice and what
might we actually use it for today I
hope to answer those questions for you
first off there are two size variants
40b for 40 billion parameters and 7B for
7 billion as well as other fine-tuned
variants the main ones being instruction
or instruct fine-tuned for Pure text
generation or if you wish to actually
fine-tune the model to some specific
task or a context subject that sort of
thing you'd probably want to use the
pre-trained bass variants but for chat
Bots q a and other sorts of back and
forth correspondence then you're
probably going to want to use the
instruct variant and then if you wanted
to fine tune a conversational model then
you might actually further fine tune the
instruct variant rather than the bass
these models are all available under the
Apache 2.0 license which is very open
and permissive of for distribution and
commercial use and so on so this makes
this a very business friendly model to
use finally the AI team behind the
Falcon models the Technology Innovation
institutes currently have an open call
for proposals for them to provide
essentially you with compute grant money
for projects that utilize the Falcon
model but more on that in a bit to start
these models are available on hugging
phase via the Transformers Library while
the 7 billion parameter model is a
little more comfortable to run locally
needing a mere 10 ish gigabytes of
memory at 8-bit the 40 billion parameter
variant can be a little more challenging
wanting more like 45 to 55 gigabytes at
8 Bits and 100 plus at 16 depending on
context length you can feel free to run
these locally even on CPU and RAM if you
want but I would personally suggest
Lambda for the two dollar an hour h100
80 gigabyte card instances they don't
pay me to say that it's just a fact they
are the best right now in terms of price
to performance on cloud hosting getting
set up to actually run the Falcon models
is most likely going to be just
upgrading to torch 2.0 since I imagine
most people are still on 1.x in some
form in the description of this video I
will have a link to my GitHub with all
relevant code and Snippets including the
install shell script that I personally
used with Lambda to get things rolling
but this would work on AWS or other
platforms as well even locally from here
we can check out a basic example of
Falcon 40b's performance and quality and
in this case it's just continuing a
thought of course though this is an
instruct model which can be more geared
towards things like instructions or a
conversation so let's try that and as
you can see already the Falcon model has
a pretty good grasp of the you know just
natural language right and it's really
quite interesting to me how fast this
like bar to be impressed by large
language models has moved since chat GPT
hit the scene late last last year like a
year ago just a year ago this alone
would have been just huge like this just
just Falcon 40b's performance right now
like would have been uh just massive
huge breaking news and when chat gbt
came out it was and suddenly we just we
just happened we just live in a world
now where we have these models that can
speak and generate text as if we're
speaking to a human or another human is
writing to us and it's an it's good
enough to convince other people that it
is another human indeed writing to us
and I think what makes Falcon and Falcon
40 be especially huge right now is
rather than needing to run all of your
queries through open AI you can just
download and run Falcon on your own or
you can fine tune it further it's yours
to do with as you please and it's just
crazy to me the the the progress that
we've made in just one year in Ai and
what's actually available to people to
use like right now in software develop
element and just the just an AI that is
available to you and now ai that is
available literally that you could just
download it's yours you do whatever you
want with it from here that's just
insane it's just insane agile students
see in some of these examples I actually
think Falcon 40b is very comparable to
Chad gbt's base model the GP or GPT 3.5
uh it's a little inferior to gpt4 but
we'll talk a little bit more about some
reasons why I think that is but also
it's just a vastly smaller model the
than gbt4 but I think we actually could
probably eke out a lot more performance
than just what the model itself right
now is outputting so how intelligent is
Falcon
for all these examples I'm going to just
use the Falcon 40b instruct model from
my very brief testing I would likely
classify Falcon 7B as best suited really
for either like few shot learning
examples or even likely as a model that
you'd further fine-tune to a very
something more specific whereas Falcon
40b especially that instruct variant is
much more suitable for just general use
and working right out of the box to
start some fairly random General
Knowledge Questions here I'm showing
what the initial prompt input was and
then the results to the best of my
knowledge these are all accurate and
good answers from Falcon 40b here as you
can see I use this sort of format in my
prompt to suggest a sort of conversation
between a user and an assistant these
names do not need to be this way or the
same or even used at all this model is
extremely open and general purpose you
don't even need there to be like one to
one like user then assistant then user
then assistant you can have something
like user assistant assistant like I'll
show example of that later too but
there's the possibilities here are very
very open so here though I do
particularly like the question about
practicing Law Without a law school
degree in the United States because most
models get this wrong and and the
question and answer itself can also
speak towards potential uh moderation
and after the fact sort of censorship or
just a bias towards safe answers if
there are concerns about models saying
incorrect or unsafe things in general
highly professional Fields like law and
Medicine carry a lot of risk if people
who are uneducated attempt to practice
it so a model is likely to be biased
away from answering this question
correctly
even though that is the truth that you
can practice law in certain states
without a law degree if attempts are
made to encourage or bias that model
towards safe answers so for example chat
gbt with GPT 3.5 gets this wrong and
says no you cannot practice law in any
state without a law degree GPT 4.0 does
actually get this right and I can't
remember if it's always gotten this
question right I want to say if memory
serves me it didn't used to get this
question right but anyway here it does
but now without multiple warnings and
what I would call cyas so it does seem
that at the very least the potential
risks in answering this question were
identified by GPT 4.0 and then it's very
careful in its response to you now
Beyond this question all the answers
indicate a wide range of accurate
knowledge that you can tap into from the
safety of drinking dehumidifier water to
the iPhone's release date to the atomic
mass of thallium and so on obviously
this is a terribly small sample size and
I'm confident that we could find wrong
answers generated by this model but as a
general purpose model this is really
surprisingly good for a mere 40 billion
parameters at least in my opinion next
up is the topic of math an area that GPT
models tend to struggle significantly
with due to the auto aggressive nature
of how they actually generate responses
going always linearly algebraic
expressions are often calculated in like
chunks and not necessarily in a linear
order of the characters that are seen
right so large language models often
struggle here for simple math problems
Falcon 40b gets the correct answer but
as you complicate things with algebraic
problems you can often find GPD models
including even gpt4 and GPT 3.5 they
begin to struggle chat GPT especially
for gpt4 uses something in the
background that will essentially convert
your math prompts to show your work
prompts so where the the machine was a
at least asked I just want this answer
it is clearly detecting that it's a math
problem and then being fed and an
additional I think prompt that is
suggesting that hey please show your
work because this is a common trick to
getting GPD models to correctly solve
problems like this that are maybe not
necessarily solved by thinking linearly
like if you need to kind of be able to
bounce around the way to do that is
essentially asking it to show its work
and the theory here is just the more
tokens that you give the model to kind
of like think through a problem that's
like token is like brain power or
something and then it also allows it to
think non-linearly now where as if you
tell it just straight up give me that
answer and nothing more it's probably
going to get it wrong I also exemplified
this example in my analyzing gpt4 video
I'll put a link to that video in the
description but here's a couple friends
from that where both GPD 3.5 and gpt4
get this right nowadays due to some GPT
post-processing or you know just tricks
that are being applied and actually GPT
3.5 got these questions used to get
these questions wrong and I actually
think using rbrms and other kind of
heuristics and techniques and stuff that
that openai learned from gpt4 I think
they just went back and applied them to
GPD 3.5 I'm just taking guesses here but
now gbd 3.5 just responds in a very
similar way to gpd4 such that I'm pretty
confident they're probably running the
exact same kind of forms and like like
pre-pre-prompts I guess or maybe a post
prompt but I don't know how I don't know
what the right word is so I'll just call
it heuristics but essentially a trick to
get the model to Think Through the
answers but you can still show that they
will both of these models will fail if
they try to just generate just the
answer and nothing more but coming back
to Falcon we can see that if we just ask
Falcon without telling it to show its
work it does get the question wrong but
if we tell Falcon hey please show your
work then it shows its work and it
actually gets the question correct
another area that some GPT models are
surprisingly impressive is this concept
of theory of Mind essentially
understanding underlying thoughts and
especially like human emotions and
behavior for situations and scenarios so
here's an example from the Sparks of AGI
paper from Microsoft that I've run
through Falcon 40b essentially the white
is the prompt and the green is the
generated answers I went one answer at a
time each time passing the entire
history up to that point in that new
question so kind of think of this as a
continued conversation between me and
Falcon 40b asking about this sort of
conversation scenario Falcon 40b here
correctly identifies that Mark isn't
necessarily unhappy with Judy's
disciplining of Jack but instead how she
went about it but also correctly
identifies how Judy is perceiving things
herself and feeling about Jack's sort of
stepping in and Falcon understands that
they're both essentially talking past
each other and even has suggestions
about how they could improve this
situation these theory of Mind examples
just always impress me as GPD models are
strangely really good at this sort of
thing often performing much better than
you might have predicted if you weren't
aware that these models are just good at
this stuff so here's another example of
theory of mind and an answer that I
think is quite good again there's
nothing in this text that suggests what
Luke's reasoning might be this is purely
an understanding of just like human sort
of psychology and emotion to attempt to
explain some incongruence between
requests statements and behavior so
again you know generally we you would
expect AI to think in this like
deterministic way and not really take
into account human emotion and like you
know odd behavior like it's really just
emotion like emotions are strange in
humans it's like as opposed to like
something like programming where
everything is deterministic and it just
it's logic right
um there's this whole other side to like
humans that is sometimes very difficult
to understand whereas uh the GPT models
and Falcon 40 be here in particular
um show a pretty good understanding of
human emotion and behavior next we have
some programming examples which is
usually my personal interest and focus
with GPT models five percent of the
training data for Falcon 40b was code
specifically but another five percent of
training data comes from conversational
sources like Reddit and stack Overflow
where code is often discussed and shows
up uh and then there's a web crawl which
also is likely to contain a lot of code
so there's a good amount of code in here
but it's certainly not close to being
the majority the first programming
example I'll show here is a regular
expression question and it's in the
format of next line predictions in an
attempt to Simply continue the sequence
much like copilot might do for you in vs
code and if it's not clear the Yellow
Part here is the prompt and the cyan is
the model's output in this case it gets
the hint for my comment again much like
I might do with copilot for example and
it proceeds to generate the regular
expression extract the prices from the
text and even print them out for me
completely in line with what you might
expect the model to generate and this is
indeed what I would have wanted next we
might instead enjoy a more
conversational approach to the same
sorts of problems so here we've got the
same exact problem just in a more q a
format in this format you might prefer
it purely because maybe you you want an
explanation like maybe from the model
here or maybe you just want it to feel
more like a teacher than a code
generator and give the more kind of
friendly feeling to the user it really
just depends what your use case is and
here I'm just showing and these are both
from Falcon 40b instruct but I'm just
kind of showing that you know again you
can you can do this you can do so many
things here it doesn't just have to be
necessarily a back and forth all right
so one more slightly more complicated
programming example uh one of my latest
projects is called term GPT which is a
project aimed at getting a GPT model to
take some sort of General objective as a
prompt and then output actual terminal
commands that could be run even
including with like os.system to
actually achieve whatever that prompt
was so this includes things like yes
writing code but also executing commands
executing that code installing packages
Reading Writing files and so on I have a
whole video covering this as well so
feel free to check that out if you're
interested I did it using gbd4 up to
this point but I would very much like to
use an open source model instead and
Falcon 40b is looking like it's at least
it's very close to achieve this with
Falcon 40b I first pass a pre-prompt
with a One-Shot example showing just
what I would like the agent to respond
with sort of like the essentially the
same thing I did with the term GPT video
but then in this case I don't actually
have to have the user specify next
because it's it's not required of me to
do like this like back and forth so in
this case I just have the user suggest
an objective and then term GPT or Falcon
40b in this case just suggests command
command command command command so the
pre-prompt shows an example of basically
what I would like and then the prompt
the actual user objective here is in
that yellow and then cyan is what the
model's output actually was the idea
here is that a user would input that
yellow part and they wouldn't even see
or really be they wouldn't know about
the white part it would just be kind of
in the back end essentially I mean they
could know about it but they're not
going to mess with that part it's just
passed there to sort of guide the model
to understand
how to structure its response and then
later we can pull apart that response
and quite literally execute those
commands just like I did in term GP so
as you can see the output is it's so
close to what we would want it really
just makes this one small mistake of
trying to create that home.html template
file in the templates directory which is
correct that is where we want it we do
want that file we do need that file that
file is correct but we never made that
directory so in the attempt to make this
file inside of that directory it's going
to fail if we did just do a maketer that
directory this would have worked and I
think this is an example of where gpd4
is better than Falcon 40b it just simply
doesn't make small mistakes like this as
often it can it totally can but just not
nearly as often and something as simple
as this gpd4 does solve out of the box
but Falcon 40b at least for my testing
both here and just in general I dare say
Falcon 40b is actually better than gbd
3.5
I also Suspect with respect to term GPT
in general I think with more time
working on a pre-prompt I could probably
iron out these problems
um and and for example gpt4's Behavior
has actually already changed on me
multiple times while I'm trying to
develop term GPT some of this is like
after the fact post-processing and kind
of like double checking the answer and
then some of that is also the the actual
underlying list I call it foundational
model has also changed now over time
that is going to keep happening and you
can specify an older model but I want to
say they are just supporting like the
single previous model and after that
it's gone and you can't get it again so
you spent all this time really like
honing in and fine tuning and getting
things just the way that you want them
to work and then the model changes or
the model doesn't even change but
clearly something something else has
changed they've changed some of that
post-processing heuristic stuff and it
just isn't working the way that you want
it anymore and that's super frustrating
whereas here with this model
you can just depend now it's not a deter
it's not totally deterministic but you
can depend if you need it to you can
depend on those weights being frozen
they are not going to change on you in
any post-processing heuristics that's up
to you so you can depend on that stuff
will not change on you but if I want to
actually fine tune it specifically to
this new use case guess what I can
actually do that too it's my model and I
just might like I was saying earlier the
tii or Technology Innovation Institute
is actually currently right now has an
open call for proposals for ideas that
you might use to on top of the Falcon
40b model and they're looking to
essentially issue grants of ten thousand
to a hundred thousand dollars in GPU
compute power uh to people who have
ideas about how they want to leverage
this exact model so something like term
GPT and I might end up submitting my own
literally for that to fine tune it to be
exactly what I want and my suspicion is
just with a little bit of fine tuning I
think Falcon 4 40b can be better than
gpt4 is right now and again at the end
of the day it's my model I can do
whatever the heck I want and I don't
have to submit my queries to open AI
anymore and I just that's that's pretty
cool so with my very anecdotal
experience so far uh I am very cautious
to say but I do think it's actually true
uh that Falcon 40b seems to actually be
better than GPT 3.5 the base chat GPT
model
struggle with saying this purely because
Falcon 40b is such a small model
relative to GPT 3.5
if if Falcon 40b was only available via
like API or some web user interface I
simply would not believe that the
outputs were from a 40 billion parameter
model alone I would just think something
else was going on like more heuristics
on top and stuff like that like gpd4
does but since we can actually download
the weights ourselves we can clearly see
no this is just the raw model output and
it's already this good which is very
impressive I very much look forward to
the forthcoming paper on the Falcon
models and training them and stuff I'm
super curious to see what techniques
were used in the actual training and the
data set I'm also confident in saying
the Falcon 40b model out of the box is
just simply not as good as the current
you know gbt4 via the API or the web
user interface but we also do know that
gpg 4 isn't just a model like this it's
a model with a bunch of heuristics on
top of it to make it quite powerful and
rumor has it that it's actually more
like eight 220 billion parameter models
essentially in an ensemble or something
like that
we we know and have some ideas about
some of those heuristics also used from
like the rbrms for example that were
shared in the open AI paper on gbd4 but
not all and everything is rumored we
really just don't know the only thing we
do know with a large degree of certainty
is that gpd4 is not just simply raw
model output from a single model
and nothing else so based on my
experience so far with Falcon 40b I
would suggest that if we like allow
ourselves to run Falcon 40b with things
like maybe rule-based reward models or
something like that like forms and sort
of Sanity checks on output and kind of
double checking or and detecting things
like is this a math problem show your
work if so you know that sort of stuff
um that I think is pretty clear that
gpt4 is using heavily I all I suspect
just in the response time it could be
based on load but there are certain
times where you ask a question and it
truly feels like you ask a question to
gpd4 and you should have already got an
answer back but you didn't but then you
get this like careful answer back and it
my suspicion again I don't know this
stuff but it feels like you're asking a
question of gpd4 it probably generated
an output and then there's another model
that sanity checks that output and if
there's something that it detects as
possibly problematic
it sends it in like a form with a bunch
of questions and the model literally
answers those answers those questions
and maybe changes the response a little
bit so my best guess is the gpt4 model
sometimes gets queried multiple times
from a single user query
um and I again I think if we if we did
the same thing with Falcon 40b I think
we would likely get far more even even
more now than we're already getting we
give far more performance out of that
model and it could be pretty comparable
to gpt4 which
is insane to think about but even if you
couldn't you can still fine-tune Falcon
40b for example
to your own specific use case and in
that in that way you are highly likely
to wind up with a better model to do
whatever it is you're trying to do then
gpd4 would be
and at the end of the day
it's yours
it's an open source model it's yours
so check out the tii call for proposals
if you have any big ideas that you'd
like to try and then also check out the
neural networks from scratch book at
nnfs.io if you're interested in learning
more about neural networks and how they
work otherwise I will see you all in the
next video